dieses Video könnte dein Leben verändern
wenn du wie ich gerne in Rührei zum
Frühstück ist dann finden wir heute
gemeinsam heraus welcher Koch das beste
Rezept für Rührei hat ich habe
herausgefunden dass Rührei ein verdammt
kontroverses Thema ist denn ich habe
mein Lieblingsrezept für Rührei auf
tiktok und auf Youtube Shorts geteilt
haben glaube ich 5 Millionen Leute
gesehen und die Mehrheit davon hat mich
beleidigt und aus diesem Grund habe ich
mich gefragt wie bereiten die besten
Köche der Welt Rührei zu also packen wir
die Eier auf den Tisch und gucken wie
Gordon Ramsi Jamie Oliver und mein
persönlicher Lieblings Koch Rührei
zubereiten unser erster Kandidat heißt
Gordon RAM sie wir gucken uns sein
Rezept an viele von euch werden es
bestimmt kennen aber gucken wir mal
reinkommen er macht es in einem Topf ich
persönlich mache immer schon Rührer in
der Pfanne aber das werden wir heute
noch häufiger sehen
als erstes Statement nicht Vorhersage
gesagt hat sag z.B mein Lieblingskoch
anders also das vorher Salzen überhaupt
gar kein Unterschied macht ihr merkt es
gibt viele verschiedene Meinungen
man darf es auch nicht vorher vermischen
also das ist der Trick
Temperaturkontrolle wir nehmen es von
der Hitze auf die Hitze so dass wir eine
weiche Textur bekommen
er gibt rein Salz Pfeffer und Creme
fraiche das habe ich noch nie in dem
Rührei gemacht glaube ich und ich bin
gespannt wie schmecken wird die
Konsistenz am Ende sieht auf jeden Fall
wild aus
same genau das wollen wir heute schaffen
deshalb legen wir los und Kochen Gordon
werden sie es früher eine Nacht hier
stehen wir jetzt und der Herr ist aus
und er bleibt auch erstmal aus während
wir unsere sechs Eier in unseren Topf
geben einfach so wie er ist neben den
Schale
es gibt die Eier drauf alles ganz
praktisch natürlich im blockbrett
einfach untergebracht Freunde vielen
lieben Dank für diesen super Lounge mit
Blog es war wirklich sehr sehr krass zu
sehen das wirklich so viele von euch
Produkte von mir bestellt haben mit
denen ich jeden Tag koche mit dem Board
die Salz Box dem scraper es ist wirklich
ein Dream deshalb Kuss an diejenigen die
bestellt haben wer noch nicht bestellt
hat und dass ich noch nicht umgeschaut
hat guckt gerne meine Shop vorbei aber
natürlich nur bestellen wenn es auch
wirklich was für euch ist und wenn ihr
mich sofort hier sind unsere Eier die
können wir schon langsam verquiren ganz
wichtig laut Gordon kein Salz rein kein
Pfeffer rein nehmen uns unsere Butter
rein und davon ein paar Scheibchen ab
ist eigentlich voll die Kleinigkeit habe
ich das Gefühl dieses Rührei Video was
wir jetzt gerade machen aber es ist auch
gleichzeitig etwas sehr sehr großes und
bedeutsames weil ohne Spaß wenn ich
heute nach diesem Video ein besseres
Rührei Rezept habe als davor habe ich
gewonnen weil wie oft mache ich mir in
diesem kleinen Dingen im Leben da zählen
auch die Unterschiede und man hat ja
gesehen wie krass das Thema polarisiert
hat Jo das hat man wirklich gemerkt also
die Leute waren die nicht wohlgesonnen
die Butter ist jetzt drin geschmolzen
sie jetzt quasi mit dem Prozess des
Aufwärmens in unser Ei hinein dabei die
ganze Zeit rühren mittlere bis obere
Hitze vielleicht kriegst du am Ende des
Tages heute eine rührpsychose aber auch
weil Höhen ist glaube ich bei allen
unseren Köchen heute auf der
Tagesordnung ist auch eine Rührei ne
jetzt beginnt es hier so ein bisschen zu
stocken und die goldenes sagt cleanen
wir es während wir kochen also die
Ränder im Boden konstant mit unserem
Gummi Schaber und jetzt machen wir es
einfach mal wie Gordon gesagt wir gehen
einmal runter von der Hitze so können
wir noch besser regulieren wie wir sie
letzten Endes kochen dann geht er wieder
drauf und dann kommt auch ein Cut und am
Ende des Tages hat eine gewohnte geile
cremige Rührei Konsistenz so wir nehmen
uns jetzt der Konsistenz die Gordon auch
hat an das heißt jetzt ist die Zeit
gekommen unsere Creme fraiche
reinzugeben ein Löffel sowie Salz und
Pfeffer wir haben die soll Konsistenz
erreicht ist verläuft nicht mehr ganz
von selbst ist aber trotzdem noch sehr
oft das heißt ich nehme jetzt runter von
der Hitze und gibt direkt einen Spachtel
auf
unserer Toastbrot hier ist unser Gordon
Ramsi Rührei etwa 10 Minuten ein
leichter Krampf in meinem Unterarm von
rühren und das ist unser Produkt
ne das hat so eine Konsistenz die ist
wirklich besonders das würde ich schon
sagen bei mir ist es sogar noch ein
bisschen feiner geworden als bei
geworden wahrscheinlich weil die Eric
meinte er einfach ein bisschen weniger
gerührt hat probieren
boah die sind wirklich unfassbar cremig
das wirklich wie Wackelpudding ich
probiere es jetzt mal mit Buttertoast
ich wünschte ich würde es ein bisschen
weniger mögen was mich gerade schon echt
genervt hat wie lange es doch gedauert
hat war das ist wahrscheinlich zum
mittags fluffigste Rührei was hier
gegessen habe so Freunde bevor es
weitergeht und jetzt das zweite Video
anschaue eine kleine Sache ich
persönlich liebe es zu kochen ich
veröffentlich zweimal die Woche ein
Video und habe sehr sehr viel Spaß an
meinem Job was wäre aber wenn ich das
alles gar nicht mehr könnte wenn ich z.B
einen Unfall hätte oder mentale Probleme
bekommen würde das Ding ist jeder vierte
Deutsche wird statistisch entlang seines
Berufslebens einmal berufsunfähig und in
den meisten Fällen geht gar nicht um
Unfälle wie viele denken sondern zu 31 %
sind psychische Sachen die zum Beispiel
Depressionen Ursache dafür was passiert
dann wenn man nicht mehr zur Arbeit
gehen kann wenn man keine Kraft mehr hat
wenn man nicht mehr arbeiten kann wer
kümmert sich dann um ein und genau hier
kommt die Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung
ins Spiel die dein Einkommen absichert
wenn es im Schadensfall ausfällt klar
hilft mir dabei und kann auch euch dabei
helfen die für euch passende
Versicherung zu finden genau auf eure
Bedürfnisse abgestimmt klar ist ein
digitaler versicherungsmanager bei dem
ihr eure Versicherung
digital einsehen könnt in der App könnt
ihr ein individuellen bedarfscheck
durchführen und so sehen wie gut ihr
aktuell versichert seid und das beste
ist die App zeigt euch aus über 180
Versicherern die besten tarifern als
kleinen Bonus könnt ihr bei eurer
Registrierung den Code Max pane eingeben
und beim Upload von drei bestehenden
Versicherungen so ein 45 Euro best
choice Gutschein bekommen ihr müsst
übrigens keine neuen Versicherung über
Clark abschließen könnt euch aber
einfach unabhängig beraten lassen ganz
ganz wichtig weil das auch häufiger
aufkam dass es mir wichtig dass es
klappt wichtig wenn ihr euch bei klar
registriert dann gebt ihr euer
maklermandat ab wenn ihr also bisher ein
Makler habt dann ist der nicht mehr für
euch verantwortlich sondern klagt es ist
also scanding QR-Code oder klickt auf
den Link in der Videobeschreibung um
euch unverbindlich zur
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung durch
klagt verraten zu lassen und übrigens ab
sofort können bei Clark auch sofort
Termine für eine Versicherung gebucht
werden für die eine persönliche Beratung
empfohlen wird also weiter geht's mit
dem nächsten Rezept gucken wir wie gut
das zweite Rührei wird kommen wir zur
Rezept Nummer 2 das ist von Jamie Oliver
und er bringt uns gleich drei Rezepte
mit von denen wir uns aber auf 1
konzentrieren werden ihr seht hier die
drei Version wir nehmen das in der Mitte
warum weil Jamie diese Version feiert
das ist ein French Rührei und die sieht
wirklich außergewöhnlich aus und hat
einen
Geheimtipps
merkt ihr den ersten Unterschied noch
bevor es losgeht er verrührt sie und
Salz die bevor er irgendwas macht genau
das von den Gordon RAM sie gerade gesagt
hat dass es überhaupt nicht geht
nicht
okay das ist der Trick wir kochen das
Rührei im Wasserbad das heißt
Glasschüssel auf den Topf und
kontinuierlich rühren das klingt
eigentlich zu einfach um wahr zu sein
ich weiß dass es ziemlich lange dauert
super vielen Dank Butter muss natürlich
auch wieder mit rein
zu Hotel
sehr sehr sexy noch feiner machen wir
uns die Arbeit boah Leute noch mal mehr
rühren noch mal mehr Zeit kann sich das
überhaupt noch lohnen weil auch die
Golden Variante hat wirklich schon lange
gedauert ich habe hier meine Schale in
die gebe ich jetzt vier Eier die ich
zunächst einmal Salzen werde die Eier
sind in der Schüssel und ich starte
unseren Timer ich möchte nämlich wissen
wie lange es wirklich dauert gebe jetzt
ein bisschen Salz zu den Eiern um sie
dann anschließend aufs Wasserbad zu
setzen höchste Stufe das Wasser unten
drunter kocht und ich darf rühren wenn
ihr das nachmacht wichtig dass ihr auch
eine hitzebeständige Glasschüssel habt
weil mir ist mal eine gesprungen als ich
sowas gemacht habe auch nicht so schön
deshalb weiß ich rühren du dich sein und
es beginnt zu stocken laut Jamie müssen
wir jetzt also holen und die Butter
kommt jetzt dazu jetzt arbeite ich mit
dem Teigschaber und hole das Ganze
gleich wenn es ein bisschen Rohr sogar
noch ist als bei Gordon runter und wir
können testen und ziemlich genau 20
Minuten später haben wir die gewünschte
Konsistenz endlich erreicht wir sind
geschlagen da ist es endlich also ich
glaube ich habe noch nie so viel Zeit
für ein Rührei aufgebracht gucken wir
uns die Eier mal an wenn du sagst das
eine war wirklich
ja das würde ich so zusammenfassen es
ist wirklich weird weil es irgendwie so
wie Mayonnaise das hat auf eine Art und
Weise wegen der Textur wirklich was
käsiges es ist lecker versteh mich nicht
falsch allein durch die Präsentation
finde ich schon nicht so lecker wie ein
anderes es schmeckt so wie nur Eigelb
fast schon irgendwie geil kommen wir zum
dritten und letzten Rezept von meinem
persönlichen Lieblings Koch kennen sie
Lopez all der ist einfach der Gold sein
wie du hast einfach nur really good
scrambit xxx
bester Mann wir fangen an indem wir
Wasser in eine Pfanne geben damit die
Pfanne gleichmäßig vorheizt wir sind
schon seine geheimen Zutat Maisstärke
das ist das Geheimnis von keny er macht
eine Soßenbinder mische also einfach
Speisestärke Wasser wird das Ganze an
und das sorgt dafür dass man die Eier
nicht so perfekt auf den Punkt kochen
muss und sie bleiben trotzdem cremig und
flüssig an alle die Detektor Kommentar
geschrieben haben lass mich bitte in
Ruhe
ich glaube wirklich das kann sich sehen
lassen und das machen wir jetzt nach es
wird Zeit für Gericht Nummer drei und
dann gucken wir wer heute gewonnen hat
lasst uns jetzt die Methode von Kenji
ausprobieren eine Sache kurz vorab ich
habe mir gesagt dass mein lieblings koch
ich habe trotzdem dieses Rezept noch nie
ausprobiert weil ich immer sofort war
und ich einfach Rührei so gemacht habe
wie es immer mache zeitmäßig dürfte das
sogar relativ flott gehen aber wir haben
ein zwei Schritte mehr als bei den
anderen Küchen fangen wir an mit unserer
Butter Schönheit aus dem Kühlschrank
schneiden wir hier so in Scheibchen also
ich glaube kennen sie benutzt auch am
meisten Butter was natürlich dafür
spricht dass es auch besonders gut ist
wir lassen uns überraschen jetzt gebe
ich nämlich erstmal ein bisschen Wasser
hier in unsere Pfanne hinein etwas so
viel und lass die auf 3/4 in der Hitze
mal ordentlich heiß werden wenn das
Wasser verdampft ist unsere Pfanne auch
perfekter Temperatur für die Butter und
fürs Kochen den Rest gebe ich mit
unserer Maisstärke zusammen und mache
hier eben unseren Soßenbinder ja unser
Geheimrezept darstellt dazu jetzt unsere
gewürfelte Butter ein Teelöffel von
unserer Stärke Mischung und wir Salzen
ebenfalls vorher ja schon ich habe jetzt
bei Jamie auch keinen Unterschied
gemerkt ich glaube das war ein Fake News
von Onkel Gordon unser Wasser ist jetzt
vollständig verdampft beinahe sowie
Kanji gebe ich jetzt meine Butter rein
rein mit den Eiern und wir sind jetzt
aber auch schon bei Temperatur jetzt
würde ich sagen ist es noch nicht ganz
dann wir haben es immer noch so ein
bisschen weich und so können wir es
jetzt schon direkt auf unseren Teller
geben ich finde das sieht aus wie so ein
richtiges Hotel Rührei vielleicht genau
so lecker probieren wir das längste
Tutorial aber die kürzeste Kochzeit das
hat keine fünf Minuten gedauert und ich
finde so sollte eigentlich auch ein
Rührei sein weil das ist ein Essen für
jeden Tag gucken wir mal ob es
vielleicht trotzdem genauso gut ist mit
weniger Aufwand boah das verzieht sich
echt sehr easy hier mit der Gabel wenn
wir wirklich mal ganz genau schauen
sehen wir das ist wirklich sehr sehr gut
mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt noch ich denke
das wird zum wesentlichen Teil daran
liegen dass wir diese Maisstärke
Mischung verwendet haben probieren wir
einfach mal ohne alles
schon wieder ein anderes Ei ja und wir
haben wirklich immer die gleichen Eier
und der gleichen Marke gekauft das ist
schon echt verdammt gut ich werde
probieren das alles auszublenden und wir
treffen uns zur finalen Bewertung wie
immer haben wir drei Kategorien Aufwand
Kosten und Geschmack wobei der Geschmack
doppelt gewertet wird also zehn mögliche
Punkte sonst 5 Thema Aufwand Gordon
readys Rührei ist nicht unaufwändig man
wird die ganze Zeit ich meine Unterarm
hat mir weh getan ich würde sagen sind
wir dabei dreieinhalb von fünf möglich
Jamie Oliver im Prinzip genau das
gleiche klar man muss keine kaufen aber
man wird noch mal doppelt so lang das
einfach ab also das ist nichts für jeden
Tag das ist was wenn man die
Schwiegereltern beeindrucken will oder
so drei von fünf kennen Sie auch kein
super einfaches Rührei du brauchst
verschiedene Zutaten hast mehrere
Schritte aber auf der anderen Seite sind
viele davon kleine Tricks vier von fünf
Kosten Gordon 4 weil man braucht kein
fresh Jamie 5 einfach nur Eier und Salz
kennen sie ebenfalls 5 weil dieses
kleine Bisschen Maisstärke was man
zusätzlich hat kostet nicht Prozent
wahrscheinlich die wohl wichtigste
Kategorie der Geschmack ich muss sagen
Gordon Rams Rührei hat mir verdammt gut
geschmeckt und hat so ein bisschen ein
Portal geöffnet in einer andere Welt des
Rührei ist deshalb 9 von 10 Punkten
Jamie Oliver war speziell das war
wirklich wie dieses käsige eigelbige
etwas ist nichts für mich ich mochte
sehr gerne aber siebeneinhalb und zu
guter Letzt kann sie für mich das nicht
ganz so next level wie das von Gordon
aber richtig gut 8,5 damit ist der
knappe Sieger des heutigen Tages kennji
ihr könnt jetzt in die Kommentare
schreiben war klar weil du ihn feierst
aber ich habe versucht ehrlich zu sein
schreibt mal in die Kommentare ob ihr
vielleicht den ein oder anderen Trick in
eurer implementieren werdet ja das war's
im heutigen Video bleibt frisch und
haltet die